record-setting outbreak of the omicron
variant the number of new cova cases
reported yesterday hit an all-time high
for the u.s more than 400 thousand with
the numbers rising so fast some doctors
say it was premature for the cdc to
lower its guidelines for isolation and
quarantine joining us now is dr celine
gaunder an infectious disease specialist
at nyu and bellevue hospitals here in
new york she was a coveted advisor for
the biden harris transition team as well
thank you so much for being with us i
want to jump in right away because there
is just so much confusion about all this
and so many people talking about
why did the cdc not add an antigen test
and and have you test negative once
you're out of this five-day isolation
period that they're now talking about
you think it's because of a lack of
tests we talked to dr wolinski a little
bit earlier from the cdc and she says
they don't really do
what we think they do that they don't
show how infectious a person is and
that's why they scrap some of this can
you break down for us what you think is
really going on
jamie i think it's a combination of both
and frankly the fda has had two years to
do these assessments that dr wolenski is
referring to
whether they're as good to make that
initial diagnosis to say you're
contagious
as they are for saying you are no longer
contagious they've had two years and
they've been dragging their feet for two
years on approving uh rapid antigen
tests initially there were only about
two that were available and then over
the summer it became clear look
vaccination is not getting us to the
other side of the pandemic as quickly as
we had hoped our vaccination rates
plateaued and there was a recognition
that testing was going to have to be a
priority and that's when the
administration when the fda started to
approve more rapid antigen tests to open
up supply but they've really dragged
their feet on this and that is really
not an excuse and that's on top of the
fact that we don't have enough rapid
antigen tests and other tests available
which i think is really indeed driving
the decision not to include that as part
of the protocol here
now the cdc says that masks should be
war another five days after isolation is
that sufficient enough
nate i i think that's sufficient if
people actually wear the mask but we
have learned over the course of the
pandemic uh that the masks have been
politicized that people are not wearing
masks when they're when they should be
uh and even if they do wear a mask
they're often wearing them on their chin
under their nose i just traveled back uh
from visiting family in missouri over
the holidays on sunday and the number of
people who were inappropriately wearing
their masks despite a federal mask
mandate was really shocking in the
middle of this omicron surge
dr gallander there is some confusion
when it comes to mask and i'm just
asking this personally you know i can be
in new york and there's a sign outside
of an establishment that says you must
wear a mask and then i go across the
bridge to jersey and i don't see that
and i don't see people wearing masks
will there be some uniformity because
you have said that we all need to up our
mass game when it comes to omicron
the challenge here is that our public
health decision making much of it
actually resides at the state and local
level so new york city can decide to
have one uh regulation and new jersey
over the border of the state can have a
different regulation and so you are
going to see patchiness across the
country in terms of what is being asked
of you
so dr gander it's vlad um what worries
you as we head into the new year i know
that we've had a pretty rough couple of
months with delta and now with omicron
could we see another variant coming down
the line that could even be more deadly
or contagious than omicron
vlad in the short term what worries me
is what this is going to mean for
hospitals we are really short staffed
right now over the holidays we work with
a skeleton crew as it is uh and then on
top of that many of our healthcare
workers are actually out sick themselves
with omicron they're not being allowed
to care for patients while infectious
logically
and so it's really hard right now to be
a healthcare provider at the hospital
and also seeing what's happening in the
community people still not taking
precautions uh seeing case rates go up
seeing hospitalizations really starting
to creep up
that's very concerning with respect to
variance there will be more variance and
the more we allow the virus to spread to
replicate every time it replicates it
mutates and some of those mutations will
give rise to more variants the way to
slow that process down the
emergence of new variants is to get more
people vaccinated as quickly as possible
when you talk about hospitalizations i
know a lot of parents are looking at the
numbers when it comes to pediatrics and
seeing those numbers creep up for kids
entering the hospital is it safe for
kids to return to in-person classes once
this holiday break is over and what do
you say to parents who have to put their
kids into daycare
this really comes down to whether all
the different mitigation measures are
being utilized so first of all if you
have a child who's five and up
they should absolutely get vaccinated
that's the best way to help reduce their
risk but on top of that we really should
be having kids uh over the age of two
wearing masks and i can tell you my
niece who's two years old she knows when
you leave the house you wear a mask
that's the first thing she grabs
in addition to her coat when she heads
out the door to the playground uh so i
think that's not an unreasonable
expectation even for young children and
then there are things like hepa air
filtration units opening doors and
windows
testing is really important here this
whole test to stay notion
where even if you've been exposed to
somebody who has coveted as a student in
the classroom as long as you continue to
test negative you can stay i think we
need to be using all of those tools at
our disposal to keep kids safe as we get
ready for the new year we have to
understand that we are still in this
fight against covert dr gounder thank
you so much for your valuable
information